this is the port of augusta in sicily
just a quick boat ride out and you can
already see the san giorgio
this italian navy ship is actually the
operations center for the humanitarian
mission called mare nostrum
with a bit less pump than we expected we
enter the belly of the 130 meter long
landing craft
at the helm is captain aldo dalfini
the san giorgio's course is in the
direction of libya a distance of 220
nautical miles or about a 14-hour trip
commander dalfini has been doing this
commute between sicily and north africa
for the humanitarian mission for weeks
now
we've rescued about 8
300 refugees
that's the size of a small town
i know i'm doing the right thing
all together the italian navy has
outfitted five vessels for operation
mare nostrum they patrol a huge expanse
of the mediterranean
this is italian warship
they contact other vessels in the area
to see if they've spotted any other
refugees trying to make it across on
boats
some boats look like cauliflower
on the bottom there's a boat with a
little hull with heads and bodies
sticking out on top
and any one of them could easily fall
overboard at any time if there are heavy
seas the boat could easily capsize
behind the bridge is the operation
center of mission mari nostrum
this is where massimo vianello is in
command he's in charge of italian
vessels operating between sicily tunisia
and the libyan coast
we're heading for the oil and gas
platforms about 60 sea miles from the
libyan coast
these offshore sites near tripoli and
zuwara are ideal landmarks for refugee
boats even without any navigation
instruments
from there they just have to continue
straight towards lampedusa and
italy easy work for the smugglers from
libya with their human cargo and it's
gotten even easier with the italian navy
intercepting their ships even before
they've reached the halfway point
there's a boat near the first gas
platform the italians tow it across
since the boat's engine has broken down
and it's out of fuel
according to international maritime law
the refugees have the right to be
rescued
another boat has been sighted from the
deck
the people are being carefully
transferred off this dangerously
overcrowded vessel women and children
first
the people on the sanjorjo receive the
refugees the elderly are exhausted
most of the refugees are from syria and
they're very relieved
this couple comes from war-torn damascus
they paid fifteen thousand dollars for
their trip via turkey then for the plane
to algeria and then further on to libya
this is the third time i'm going this is
the same way third time yeah
the third time third time going and
someone catch from libya and they come
back
i don't know from government they take
us someone
take us and take our money
everyone have two thousand dollar three
thousand dollar they take all with
mobile and then you go back in some no
we call
our family from swede i am from my
family from they said i said please
transfer money
police checked the refugees passports
before they even get ashore it's a tense
moment since they don't really want to
stay in italy
if their fingerprints are taken it would
make it impossible for them to apply as
refugees in another eu country if your
family going in sweden and your
fingerprint in italy so this is problem
i have to stay because if i go to sweden
they will finger me my fingerprint they
will
discover
i already
put my finger in italy so they will come
back to me
authorities at the united nations in
rome are aware of the situation
the italians often don't register
refugees from eritrea and syria turning
a blind eye to eu immigration laws
the people who come here already know
they can refuse or should refuse to be
fingerprinted
otherwise they would be stuck in italy
not be able to travel elsewhere in
europe
or if
mainly the syrians and the eritreans
make use of this loophole regularly
and they make up half of all of italy's
boat people
for cases like muhammad's refugee
organizations are demanding new rules
for instance if a refugee has relatives
in europe that person should have the
right to temporary asylum
that would also relieve the italians who
are currently playing host to tens of
thousands of refugees
until things change the sanjorjo will
continue patrols and keep picking up
boat people
just like muhammad and his family most
of them want to move on to northern
europe legally or illegally